are going to begin though this morning
with a good sign in the effort to keep
your children safe from covet pfizer has
just announced that a lower dose of its
coronavirus vaccine appears we say
appears to be safe for children ages 5
to 11. now while the data still needs to
be submitted to the fda this could be a
big big step towards making the vaccine
available to that age group this comes
after an independent fda advisory panel
declined to recommend pfizer booster
shots for most americans it did
recommend them for high-risk patients in
people 65 and over mola lange is
following this story muller good morning
to you
good morning gail you know this is the
first pivotal trial of any covid vaccine
in children under 12 years old and it
comes at a time when covet 19 cases in
children have been skyrocketing as many
kids are going back to school cbs news
spoke to one family that participated in
the trial about the importance of
getting children vaccinated as soon as
possible
i think it's just been a really
wonderful privilege really to contribute
in this way dr richard chung is an
adolescent medicine specialist at duke
health in durham north carolina chung's
youngest son and eight-year-old joshua
took part in pfizer's recently completed
trials for children ages 5 to 11 years
old i think that everybody should get
vaccinated so that things can return
back to normal pfizer announced this
morning that the trials joshua took part
in showed the vaccine was safe well
tolerated and resulted in robust
neutralizing antibody responses those
positive results mean pfizer will now
send this data to regulatory agencies
around the world including the fda and
european medicines agency for approval
the company also said that trial results
in children under five could be
available by the end of the year the
vaccine has already been approved by the
fda for use in children 12 and up dr
chung's older son caleb took part in
those trials i wanted to participate in
the trial in order to
help motivate other kids to get the
vaccine once it became available
pfizer's announcement comes at a pivotal
time in the fight against covid19
particularly amongst children many of
whom have just recently returned to the
classroom the most recent american
academy of pediatrics reports showed the
second highest number of childhood
coveted cases for any week since the
pandemic began the spike in cases has
been driven by the delta variant which
has disproportionately affected the
unvaccinated i'm really proud of them
you know seeing them kind of
courageously take this step and to do so
really enthusiastically um has just been
a remarkable experience not just as a
pediatrician but certainly as a dad
now children receive a smaller dosage of
vaccine than adults but we should note
that eight-year-old joshua is not sure
whether he received the placebo shot or
the real vaccine he told us his symptoms
were not severe tony that's why they
call it a trial mullah thank you very
much